[Music]
nikki
i think you're gonna like this next
article hey
is it about eminem uh no but do you see
this little furry uh
animal here it's about chats yes i'm a
cat person too with my own two cats
and you want another one no no thank you
i i know you have like
a gazelle i don't know you're almost
convincing me though
but no we can't have three cats so the
cat world and the
app world are now colliding in the
in the form of an app that will now
translate
what your cat is about
i downloaded it because he told me about
the story and we tested it out with our
kitties
and what did it would they say to you
well the thing is our cats don't meow
that much
but the little bit of mailing that we i
did capture was because i had like a
little treat in front of them yeah and
then it did translate properly
which is feed me really [ __ ] yo
what the [ __ ] have you seen those tick
tocks where they put out like the sound
boards and then the
animal goes over and like says full
sentences the dog's like
i love that walk yeah and then she's
like not right now
when really yeah it's pretty cool
it's pretty crazy okay i want to hear
about this i need to know more about how
long does it take to train
a dog to do that and then she'll go like
i love you
i love you my dog ever did that i just
cried nearly on the spot
it was so cute so tell me more about
this uh cat yeah
for the software so every cat has a
different meow for different things but
really there are like somewhat universal
tones
right in which uh i don't have the list
on me actually
can you pull it up what's the list try
it because i feel like i know what my
cat's saying
all the time and that sounds weird but
steve also says this and he never
thought
he never believed before but now we've
been together for seven years
so he's been with my cats for that long
and he knows what they say now too and
we agree
on what they say what are they saying
i'm hungry in the morning like
no so my one cat and they all have
different personalities but like my
original cat um he has a system like he
yeah he's the og he's like a military
cat he like needs me to be awake at the
exact same time every day
so i feel like he jumps up and he goes
it's time to get up
like it's time to get up hey you better
get up and then
like he gets more and more aggressive
and then i'll shove him off and he has a
snooze button so he'll go away for
exactly 10 minutes
yes because my um my phone was next to
me so i would like see it and
he would go away every 10 minutes and
then he gets more and more aggressive so
he starts like
biting my hair like getting like really
crazy why is it because he wants to feed
you
so i go feed them but he doesn't eat he
just makes sure all the other
well the one other cat eats and now we
have two other cats yeah so he makes
sure they eat
so he just supervises like alpha and he
supervises from the doorway of the
kitchen like he just watches them eat so
when does he eat and then he waits till
that for them to be done and then he
goes over there and he eats he wants to
eat alone and then he goes back up to
bed
oh damn wait so have you tried feeding
him
and then going back to sleep um yeah and
does he come bug you after like telling
you to wake up he comes back and
snuggles
feed me feed me it's not a feed me
because he doesn't really care if i
eat some sometimes or if he eats so
sometimes i'll like go in the other room
and he's just happy that i'm up like he
just wants me to be up
but he does like the routine like he
does like me to feed the other cat yeah
sometimes he doesn't even touch the food
like it's just normal he's just like
this is normal if you don't do this
yeah and then if we go on vacation he
gets
really sad like he gets really
devastated yeah
does he hate you when you come back he
just he misses me
but then he gets he's very stressed like
he's gets really clean i have it too oh
nice
now all right so yeah the app is called
meowtalk
you guys if any cat people out there you
guys can download it and check it out
for yourself now
so this here right here on this side
there's a list of
uh i guess like phrases that cats
universally
uh meow or boring is at the top of the
tag is like
probably yeah probably so there's boring
i'm angry
i'm going to attack i'm going to attempt
oh there's two of them
uh i'm hunting uh i'm in love mommy
where are you
oh cool yeah like this is this is zoe
saying feed me
how do you know how do you know the no
because it saves the recording and it
was while she was giving a treat
yeah it was always giving him a treat
this one's like i'm hunting which i
think
it's not thank you if you're giving them
a treat no no this is because i don't
think they're smiling
i'm so grateful for you yeah did she
ever say thank you
this one was though uh oh yeah but um
but yeah and then this one's like i'm
hunting according to the app
sounds exactly the same can't tell
that's crazy and then this is maya's i'm
hunting
it didn't work it didn't save you did
this one this morning
you did it no no i'm not saying that no
but i'm saying like we were recording
this morning i don't think it's my
friend has a really vocal cat
uh in vietnam right every time i woke up
he would come up and go
that's obnoxious sounding but just let's
try the app right now and see what that
does yeah
yeah yeah can we imitate the cat voices
and see if it says
what it says but so
zoe does this thing at night usually at
night when we're like already in bed he
gets his
ball he puts it in his mouth and he
starts going
like really really loud and that's why i
downloaded the app last night because
i'm like i hope he does it tonight but
he didn't because i wanted to record it
if i saw you downloading this why i know
i don't want to know and then also to
get him to like to capture the meows i
have the phone like this close to him
his face so he's like the [ __ ] is that
so he's not really meowing
but i really want to catch it and i
really want to see if the app tells me
like i'm bored because i think that's
what it means
he wants to play with us and then when
we play with him for a little bit
i'm like okay fine let me get the cat
toy out here just run around for a
little bit and then
okay shut up let me go to sleep and then
it works like he'll stop meowing
but really i think it means like i want
to play yeah
or i want wait are these the only ones
that they have no you can make your own
that's the whole reason right you can't
wait you can make your own you can't
or you can reassign then so right here
it saved all of the
all of oh you guys can see but it saved
all of the recordings kind of like that
photo
and then it allows me to change
translation and when it change
translation
it gives me this list it's feed me let
me in let me out
unknown i'm angry leave me alone i'm
going to attack
hello there i'm hunting i'm in love
mommy
because it knows like i registered as me
so it goes mommy
i'm in pain i'm resting i don't know so
you can change all of them to say
i'm in love and then it's like man my
cat loves me you lie to yourself yeah
so when the cats vocalizes something the
phone picks it up and says
i'm in love well it gives you a
suggestion of the translation and then
the more you
and then it asks you like is it this
which is what they're guessing and then
if i know for a fact that it's meowing
for another reason then i could
change it and put one of these other
reasons and then the more
i teach the app the more it learns and
then it's like more actually so then
you're translating for the app not the
app translating for you right
exactly so it's just memorizing the
sound yeah i guess to learn who your cat
is because since we have two cats i
created a profile for each cat
learns each cat's vocabulary damn yeah
dogs are so much easier you know what
the [ __ ] they want
they bring a bone up to you and start
wagging their tail
like can you take this from my mouth
full
[Laughter]
they have a they have a ball and then
they're like yeah i know what they do
that's the thing they're like ready
let's do it
throw it how cute or like they get the
bowl and then they start scratching it
i'm hungry come on thank you that's cute
but the cat's
right or right it's just again it also
sounds the same
when we are fostering kittens he gets
really disturbed and stressed out by all
the kittens and so hello pace the
hallways going
wow
[Music]
getting that stress out yeah what does
that mean yeah he doesn't like
there's too many cats whenever there's a
disturbance in his routine at all and
this is the other cat but
um not the alarm clock cat he's a really
good cat
but this one he any sort of difference
like if we bought it we bought a new
couch recently he doesn't like
chains that's joe at all joe um he pees
on it we got a we got a couch cover just
because we knew
yeah because he that's what he does when
he's like stressed out yeah
makes it his and it's a waterproof
yeah he peed and yeah yeah it was like
it's like my couch was wearing a diaper
and it [ __ ] sucks dude that's our
couch too what the [ __ ]
sucks why because your cat's pee on it
it's not piss
[ __ ] poop he poops on our couch so is he
stressed do you think
no it's it's his way of telling us like
you [ __ ] didn't clean my kitty
litter it needs to be pristine it has to
be this exact texture because
you [ __ ] keep changing my kitty
letter to different types of litters
and no i want this one this exact cat
needs to be thrown out
yeah so your shit's on your couch you
got a bougie cat i'm all like what
and then when we cover our couch because
now we have i bought these like
acupressure
is that what does that one say like i'm
being thrown out in a parachute i need a
parachute
and then if we leave our bedroom door
open he'll poop on our bed
to let us know hey damn i know you you
tried covering your couch
but i'm still gonna poop on your bed so
let you know luckily he hasn't pooped on
the upstairs couch
i don't know why but he won't touch that
when you guys go home today you're going
to find a nice little
little nugget on here no we're not
because we're staying on top of him you
never talk to him like you know there's
other cats in
other countries oh i talked to him i
don't have it as good i'm like you know
i give you a good life and i feed you
well and i just try to love you so
much why do you do this to me isaac's
like at least it's not me getting this
talk this time
that's true no isaac actually got really
cocky about it he was like
well zone never poops on my bed and then
literally later that
week or a day or something like that
shortly after she heard it
no he he heard he pooped on his bed
and then kate and isaac was just so like
what the [ __ ]
i want a [ __ ] i would have [ __ ] in his
litter there yeah yeah dude and it was
so funny it does nothing for them
i was like i thought zoe loved you more
and i thought it was because you
you give him treats and all this [ __ ]
and he was just like do cats
like claim like their own bed or like
their nesting area um
yeah you sleep everywhere well that both
they do have their favorite they have
their favorite spots and also they like
to be where the people are they like to
be where the action is
so where do they sleep so they well my
my one cat sleeps with me
right here up on my bed like inside your
arm yeah like he he looks a
side spoon like he likes to be the
little spoon and then the other cat
sleeps on the foot of the bed
oh and he likes to like guard like he's
like watching out
from the food they have cat beds like
dog beds yeah they do
and then they'll claim it they're like
that's there's cat towers with beds on
them
oh yeah are there are there dog towers
out there
no cool thing to get to know their
personalities too because for example
with ours
like the boy oh so we have we bought
these two little like cat home
thingies that are like really plush
really soft and it's like kind of like a
little cocoon because we noticed that
they liked
to like burrow under things right and
then so we got two of them one for each
cat but then we realized that
only maya uses it and zone never used it
so we got rid of one of the
little houses and maya's the only one
that likes to use it
you should give them a cat tower and
[ __ ] on it yeah you let me go
who's boss [ __ ] a cat i feel about that
and they're like
and they sleep in it do your cats ever
uh bring you guys like dead animals and
stuff my old cat did
uh what my childhood cat like dead rats
um
i don't know i don't let my cats now go
outside like they've been indoor cats
only so
they'll try to catch spiders sometimes
but they get pretty scared they're kind
of [ __ ]
they like useless comes like they'll be
like oh i'm gonna get it and then it
starts coming at them they're like oh no
no no
no no no no domesticated cats with
[ __ ]
that's so funny because well maya does
that zoe is a hunter
oh yeah goes after these things like
they'll torture the place we used to get
crickets in
all the time try again no
yeah he goes like that literally like he
plays with them and it reminds me of
scar with the little mouse oh yeah
they play with their food yeah like he
totally plays with it and
after a while he gets bored and i think
maybe he accidentally kills it or
something but he's
playing eat the bugs and stuff
eventually they're like i'm bored with
you
yeah and then just eat it oh yeah my cat
one of them will like half eat a fly and
it's still like it's like arriving and
it's like he's like
and then he just eats it again
you